que la Fête du Cinéma démarre dimanche
le 30 juin pour 4 jours et cette année
la particularité c'est que nous avons
une nouvelle tarification qui est mise
en place pour tous les cinémas à savoir
un tarif unique de 3,50 € la place alors
qu'en pensent les professionnel du
cinéma bah c'est la question qu'on a
envie de vous poser et pour cela nous
recevons deux directeurs de cinéma mais
avant d'écouter votre réponse chute
messieur vous avez le droit d' vous avez
le temps d' réfléchir euh on va regarder
la bonne annonce justement de de cette
fête du
cinéma
pitro avance mon petit
bien je suis venu dès que j'ai pu très
bien assiè-toi je dois te demander un
service Pierro tu vas les surveiller les
Français du dimanche 30 juin au mercredi
juillet 4 jours et con bien pi hein
ouais mais bon 4 jours
tu ser pas en train de me refuser
quelque
chose propos à
luig
pour
aller ciné çaour
bien cé fac depuis quand les Françis
font les choses facilement
c'est nouveau Pietro la nouvelle fête du
cinéma arrive la Fête du Cinéma du
dimanche 30 juin au mercredi 3 juillet
c'est 3,50 € dès la première séance
allez gr gr alors voilà un tarif unique
cette année de 3,50 € avant pour rappel
la première place était payée plein poôt
suivi des des toutes les autres à 2,50 €
alors messieurs professionnels du cinéma
j'ai envie de vous demander qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de cette nouvelle
tarriification Luc qu déjà peut-être
mais moi je alors moi c'est un peu
compliqué parce que on vient de rouvrir
au public comme tu vous le savez au mois
d'avril donc on na pas vécu les deux
fêtes du cinéma antérieur moi j'en étais
resté pour tout vous dire au Passeport
acheté plein pot comme tu dis et puis à
la place qui était à 1,50 € je crois
qu'à l'époque c'était ça 1,50 € ou bon
c'est vrai qu' a il y a eu des
variations depuis 1985 de cette mise en
place de la fête du cinéma on a eu des
jours plus longs après c'est revenu à TR
ou 4 jours des tarifs pareils qui qui
ont évolué peur que ça devienne un peu
illisible à force de de changer les
choses de formul les an bon là c'est
clair mais c'est vrai que c'est plus la
rentrée du cinéma une opération qui
existe déjà c'est la même chose en fait
ils se sont alignés sur la rentrée du
cinéma 3,50 € bon nous on y va hein
cette année bien sûr on a 9 film à
l'affiche sur trois salles et cetera
avec des des créneaux horaires qui sont
qui sont importants qui sont augmentés
par rapport à l'habitude on tente le
coup bien sûr mais moi je suis pas
convaincu de la formule 3,50 € on a des
tarifs qui sont déjà assez bas alors
c'est c'est ça toute la la discussion en
effet Gael Pinot pour le le grenier àel
alors avec l'expérience des fêes l'année
dernière c'était 2,50 € ouais donc là on
est à 3,50 € on augmente quand même
sensiblement
euh nous ça de toute façon la fête du
cinéma je rappelle le grenier à il y a
qu'une salle donc on n pas énormément de
choix à proposer avec les les films qui
sont maintenant en numérique il y a des
conditions d'accès aux films qui sont
plus difficiles qu'avant et malgré ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer donc en plus on
a les films plus tard et plus
difficilement faut leur faire plus de
placates et cetera donc moi je j'ai pas
cherché à faire plein de séances à
mettre plein de films j'ai rien changé
par rapport aux années précédentes j'ai
rien changé ça de toute façon les gens
restent pas pour enchaîner la séance
d'après chez nous et effectivement comme
l'a dit Luc notre tarif de base en tarif
moyen de toute façon il est il est assez
bas et on n'est pas très loin de ces
3,50 € on a un abonnement qui revient à
4,30 € la place il peuvent venir aussi
souvent qu'il veulent c'est toute
l'année VO c'est c'est peut-être ça
finalement la différence des cinémas de
proximité avec les multiplex c'est vrai
que pour un spectateur euh qui qui se
rendrait dans un multiplex évidemment au
lieu de payer 10 € sa séance plein pot
mais là plus que 3,50 c'est intéressant
c'est une vraie incitation pour les
cinémas indépendants voilà est-ce que
c'est vraiment un neufux d'ben pas
forcément on verra moi je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un peu la fête du
du cinéma dans les multiplexes la fête
du cinéma mais depuis plusieurs années
hein pour les multiplex pour les
multiplexes mais je je ça se comprend
c'estàd que vu l'offre vu le nombre
d'écrans qu'ils ont et l'offre de films
qu'ils ont c'est vrai qu'on peut être
tenté
et les tarifs qui sont beaucoup plus
élevés que les nôtres on peut être tenté
d'aller passer sa journée par exemple à
Sky West et se dire j'enchane 6 ou 7 ou
projection quoi en tout cas les
distributeurs de film jouent le jeu et
sortent des films assez importants pour
la fête du cinéma c'est un enjeu pour
vous en terme de programmation parce que
bon alors pour le Gren il y a pas
forcément il y a qu'une salle donc
est-ce que vous mettez en place une
programmation spécifique donc je non du
coup non pas spécifique mais nous moi je
me démarre sur sur une programmation qui
est qui sort qui sort de de l'ordinaire
et donc cette semaine par exemple on a
un film libanais l'attentat on a un film
japonais qui s'appelle shokuza qui en
deux parties le deuxième partie sera la
semaine prochaine donc profitez de la
fête du cinéma pour voir la première et
voir la deuxème et One Piece dessin
animé japonais pour les enfants moi
voilài je m'arrête là d'accord alors
nous moi oui moi j'ai essayé par contre
de de de varier les gens c'est qu'il y a
neuf films à l'affiche est-ce que tu
connais tous les titres alors le piège
il il le savait en plus il le savait
c'est même pas nous qui posons la
questionou merci g Le on a moins moche
et méchant donc on parlait tout à
l'heure bon ça c'est facile sorti
nationale mais bon je pense que le film
est réussi enfin en tout cas j'ai l'ai
pas vu encore mais tout ce que j'ai lu
semble très positif on l'a sorti cet
après-midi ça marche vachement bien donc
ça c'est public familial qui on ve dire
on a aussi un gros blogbuster un peu en
fin de carrière Fast and Furious on a on
a demiœur on est et puis on a aussi une
offre à ressai puisque comme je vous
l'avais déjà expliqué on veut aussi
renforcer l'offre à ressai sur le cinés
bon ce qui est un peu dommage c'est
qu'on est un de ces films à ressa qui
soit le même puis que vient de parler de
l'attentat donc nous aussi on a
l'attentat en VO B alors mieurs il va
falloir vous inviter sur fil pour que
vous mettiez
d'accord c'est l'occasion peut-être de
de parler justement de cet aspect qui
est important promouvoir le cinéma donc
là dans le cadre de la Fête du cinéma
c'est une chose mais on on se rend
compte que c'est davantage orienté
multiplex quand même alors pour les
cinémas indépendants qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez mettre en place pour promouvoir
le cinéma déjà actuellement nous avons
un abonnement commun qui permet d'avoir
pas une seule salle mais pas trois
salles mais quatre salles plus Fontenel
Fleury les clés sous bois donc ça fait
ça fait déjà plusieurs salles plusieurs
cinémas plusieurs films donc finalement
c'est un travail en réseau c'est ça bien
sûr qui existe depuis de de nombreuses
années je te laisse terminer c'est ça
qui existe depuis truses années c'est ce
que je voulais dire
et et on est plus sur
euh ça sert à rien de de de de mettre en
évidence les films les plus connus euh
c'est pas à nous de faire ce travail là
de toute façon les distributeurs la
publicité le font bien nous notre
travail c'est plus de mettre l'accent
sur des films l'attenta par exemple qui
a pas eu une presse énorme et pourtant
qui un film bien un gros coup de cœur de
la preuve on est on est de Sales à
l'avoir choisi sur le même territoire
c'est mais vous confrontez votre
programmation justement est-ce que vous
concertez pas suffisamment pas
suffisamment à mon à mon à mon sens mais
c'est des choses don je vous présente
oui non mais on se connait très bien on
travaille ensem toute l'année he avec
les sal que Gael vient de citer c'est
vrai qu'on a je pense peut-être des
progrès à faire alors l'abonnement
commun c'est un truc qui fonctionne très
bien entre les salles et cetera les gens
vont vont dans dans le réseau de salle
de proximité nous c'est ça qu'on veut
promouvoir c'est ce travail de terrain
c'est la vie de nos cités nos quartiers
nos centrre-ville et cetera bon voilà
après je pense qu'on a des choses à
faire mais on est on a déjà beaucoup de
travail et on essaye je pense qu'on a
vraiment la volonté il y a aucun espèce
de problème entre nous par rapport à ça
de de nourrir ce réseau donc il y a la
carte d'abonnement il y a les dispositif
c'est 43 € c'est ça 43 € 10 places
valable à trappe euh à fon Fleury pardon
au clés sous-bois et à encours donc
indifféremment les gens peuvent acheter
les cartes dans dans dans chacun des
quatre lieux et aller dans les autres
lieux avec la même carte donc ça en plus
on s'est modernisé parce qu' mainmeants
on a une carte comment dirais-je à à CB
avec 10 places préchargé qui peut être
re charargé avancer des des chquers
papiers et cetera donc on fait des
efforts quand même he voilà bon après on
a quand même tout le travail qu'on metne
ensemble sur les dispositifs d'éducation
à l'image qui qui nous prennent beaucoup
de temps mais qui sont essentiels à nos
yeux parce que on forme sans être
prétentieux enfin on participe en tout
cas à la formation des spectateurs de
demain donc c'est École et cinéma c'est
colég cinéma beaucoup de travail avec le
le jeune public lycéen au cinéma et ces
premiers plans aussi qu'il faut pas que
j'oublie qu' a un dispositif qu'on a
créé dans lequel euh nous a rejoint
saint-cir dès le départ d'ailleurs
sacire l'école et boisarc qu qui vient
de nous quitter il qui vientnent de
sortir du plateau et il participe cette
année à premier plan pour la première
fois voilà donc ça c'est un gros travail
qu'on metne ensemble et puis on a le
projet de structurer mononde de ciné de
lui donner une forme juridique sous
forme associative on a des idées de
festival on a des idées d'animation
culturelles mené en commun et cetera
mais ce que tu veux dire c'est qu'on
fait beaucoup de choses faut pas croire
qu'on est juste derrière nos catalogues
à choisir quel film on va prendre et à
regarder les films proximité voilà il y
a plein d'avantages à y aller au final
indépendamment de la fête du y compris
mais indépendamment de la Fête du Cinéma
bah on vous souhaite beaucoup de public
alors sur ces 4 jours merci à tous les
deux be merci petite info en plus quand
même sur la Fête du Cinéma ah oui parce
que alors évidemment nouvelle
tarification bah est lancé du coup à
cette occasion un jeu concours qui est
voilà un jeu concours qui permet en
l'occurrence de gagner des voyages pour
Hollywood pour le festival de Cann 2014
donc avec un système de cartes à gratter
on verra si en a des gagnants yulinois
voilà donc la fête du cinéma c'est du 30
juin au 3
juillet c'est du coup on change de on a
deux semaines cinéma dans ces 4 jours
c'est qu'il y a le mercredi qui est une
nouvelle semaine donc on change de film
donc moi je vous ai parlé des trois
films de la première semaine mais on
aussi oui al moi j'ai dit 3 juillet
c'est le 4 juillet en fait voilà de
dimanches à mercredi
prochain voilà c'est ça
l'informationnière beaucoup